hey we wants to a great documentary the
other watch several but the one that
really hit home for me was at the fork
at the Fort Worth rap what it is is it's
about and it's a it's a document about
guy and he's a filmmaker and he has a
wife who's a vegetarian and his he comes
from a deep Italian family they do
barbecue ribs right and he was just
basically like you don't know the
suffering these animals go through and
whatnot and you should you know to kind
of explore something on this top act and
so he did a documentary about it and it
was really eye-opening night
yeah III think that people might be
turned off at the idea that maybe this
is trying to like push like veganism or
a novelty but it doesn't it actually
just it's very unbiased in the sense
that it just it tells you to just be
responsible about the where you get your
meat like wait wait I miss what you said
the whole thing yeah like my mind wasn't
even here I swear to God I don't know
what happened up sup sup I knew you know
why what was it because when I was
talking about it this is what you did
this is what you did if you can say it
on this I sometime he doesn't look at me
and he's looking at something else yeah
like I'm in the car with up dude and
like we'll be driving and I'll be
talking about them and I'll look over
and he'll just be like it's like right
did that I don't know I've had that for
a while I'm so sorry what is that that
you're not hearing voices no no no it's
like I just - now what were you thinking
about though I had a dream about you the
other night no sorry don't look at me
right now you Vegas area no I'm serious
what was the dream if we're you may you
weren't there you were in the dream but
you sent me and Bob you lived in San
Diego in a house you that's where you
lived in a house in San Diego yeah and
um and then the whole reason why you
lived there is because you're like I
don't like I like the commute from San
Diego to LA I
wrote it down oh please tell my brother
wrote down sweet it cuz right when I
walk can I read it maybe if I could
realize these let me see if I could just
read as a handwriting let me just read
it I won't read it online there's a
grocery let me see let me see oh it is
true Gilbert look at it says right here
I know hop Gilbert dream please read it
can I read it
yeah well it won't make any sense I
think you can let me go let's interpret
it okay my brother wrote down on a piece
of paper Gilbert dream in a parenthesis
not parenthesis I seize those unpleasant
see what do you call those parentheses
parentheses I could get bracket you San
Diego house Mira Mesa question mark Papa
house pasta sausage stop jalapenos is
one bedroom no bedroom
San Diego house oh yeah and this is I
left room you guys order working move
back and forth are my dog [ __ ] okay get
on your carpet resolve spray resolve
spray yeah Bob went down
kalila said us went to gas station just
set you Bloods Philly's a pack
it's a zigzag what it's a snow slide
shove it knows like shove it infant
recognize a a blank dude wow that's like
very poetic so no that's your next song
yeah so what happened was good listen to
Mike okay so what happened was you live
down there and so we're in your living
room and I like went outside and you
guys had ordered food without me like
Papa John's
no you had it delivered and what this
but it was from Papa John's it no Papa
Howie's what's poppin house
it's just the name of this Italian
restaurant
really no it was a real place in my
dream and the way the real real live no
no in your dream it was Papa Howie's
well you ordered Papa Howie I were a
Papa Howie
but yeah that's your favorite but Papa
Howie's doesn't exist isn't it so in
your mind you created Papa Howie
Papa Howie's in my demo so Papa how is
you go ahead and I went into the back
into the house yeah and you're eating
this delicious delicious delicious pasta
platter and it had those long sausages
you would get in pasta but then
meatballs
- so meatballs long sausage and
jalapenos and I remember in the dream
like oh you guys didn't order me any and
then you guys were eating it like like
really enjoying that so I left and then
somehow okay commute back and forth and
then my mom entered the dream I don't
know when that happened but she stepped
in [ __ ] and try to go on your carpet
and got it I used the results spring
yeah because I think that's that year
and my mom has it at home
[Music]
yeah so so good I'm glad I read it first
now everything's cleared up yeah resolve
spray to get this [ __ ] out of the car
because that's resolved sprays hit my
mom and dad's in Gilbert okay and then
somehow we ended up the gas station
because you wanted to
you had weed and then I got you you like
you want two blunts and I got a Phileas
eight pack points and that's when I did
the skate there's red curbs and I did a
skate trick and then oh no it's what you
do and then these guys in AAA
walked up oh hey what are you guys doing
here in San Diego - and then now it's a
dream how did you feel why didn't you I
wrote it down the reason why I wrote
down because there's details in the
dream you know what I'm saying of
rotation of it I don't know it was your
house is your house maybe because you
had just come back from Gilbert Arizona
oh there is a correlation with my name
and the city I'm sorry I made you CEO
just stuck with me I'm like I got it I
don't know what did you write that down
last night two or three nights ago well
right when I woke up I i'm like you know
i should write because i remembered the
name of them i tell you italian
restaurant listen yeah pasta dish
marinara sauce yeah
meatballs and sausage and long jalapenos
know jalapeno harder that in every that
exists George that was weird I don't
know yeah well that was really
interesting yeah why did you always
write down your dreams with other first
time no there's a couple I have a couple
like a notebook I have a couple dreams
right here's why here's what he tales do
is
we need you to calm and and read some of
your dream book to us yeah well start a
dream book he has one yeah details huh
didn't know let me ask you did it when
he read the stuff did it sound like a
crazy person wrote it no it just sounded
like you were dying down notes oh well
yeah to trigger the memory why did you
keep that I don't know it because I I
knew I would see you and I'm like you
know I'll just be interesting too but
what is he gonna go that's cool dude no
I don't know what it meant I don't know
why yeah I don't know why maybe we
should analyze it well can we get a
maybe a dream interpreter now how do we
do that when we figured it out Gilbert
Arizona it might not be that too it
might be how you feel about Gilbert yeah
San Diego you don't want him near you
he's so not the type to smoke blunts
either no yeah maybe it's his future
look a show that I moved to sin no get
out of there you get so depressed you
start smoking blunts San Diego though
yeah but you're such a foodie so you
open a rest house then I like to commute
to LA for no reason oh yeah it's the
only thing you can hang on to
yeah Oh something's about to happen to
you this year [ __ ] I'm sorry but think
of how I papa how are you maybe you'll
have your own Italian chain a restaurant
Steve sharp okay we'll get off you know
how much improvement
[Music]